[Music]
so
and welcome to rt's no bs podcast
today focusing on the issue of
coronavirus so much
that has been discussed in the media it
seems like we talk about coronavirus
uh in one way or another every single
day it is maybe the most
impactful thing happening in the world
for the last year and
certainly uh even though a lot of people
had hoped by this time
things would have been wrapped up with
the coronavirus that things would be
more under control
it feels as if things are less under
control than they've
under control than they've ever been
that we're seeing now a talk of
more lockdowns on their way more
economic shutdowns coming
and of course discussion over whether or
not mask
mandates will follow going all the way
into 2021 maybe all the way through
2021 and then of course the big question
the question
of what do we do about the vaccine the
vaccine that's on its way from multiple
big pharma companies that are developing
this in multiple nations it's been
developed
the question of course will you take the
vaccine will you even have a choice
we're gonna talk about all these issues
today
uh in a format that you probably have
not seen before over the next 90 minutes
we're bringing in
a whole series of guests looking at this
from a variety of angles
i am ben swann i'm glad to be with you
during this time i want to just
begin by telling you something that i
was speaking to a friend
just last night and that friend shared
with me that in thinking about the
coronavirus they said
i don't know what to believe about
anything anymore because
i don't know that i can trust media and
so one of the things we want to do today
is try to clear up and bring clarity
uh from our guests about what is
happening around the world and what will
continue to happen
over the next few months so let's bring
in our first two guests and we'll be
transitioning in and out of guests
throughout this 90 minutes
we want to begin with economist david
blanchflower and professor dimitri
khalish of skulltech thank you both for
being here i want to bring you both into
this
and uh let's start david with the
economy because it really is on
everyone's mind
it's something that so many people are
concerned about
obviously so many people uh concerned
about what is ultimately going to happen
over the next few months and going into
next year
around the world in terms of the economy
here in the u.s and around the world
so one of the things that we have seen
in the past is this discussion of
economic shutdowns and lockdowns
has it been successful will we see it
again what say you
well i think the initial shutdowns do
appear to have had an effect but i think
the reality
is when you look at things like what
happens to economies
authorities just didn't really have the
courage to do enough
and it's not as if we haven't been here
before i have in front of me the great
book by john barry
on the great influenza his conclusion in
that is one thing
the authorities should tell the truth
and i think that's not what's happened
so we have a lack of trust
people especially in america people are
just not listening to what the
government says
and they're obviously fearful so what
we're seeing is this enormous spread
with thanksgiving coming
people don't trust what's happening and
they probably don't trust whether to
take this vaccine or not
so what's happened is a sort of virus
crisis has become an economic
crisis well
it certainly is an economic crisis and
of course there's a lot of talk right
now here in the u.s certainly
of new lockdowns being instituted mayor
bill de blasio in new york just said
what last week that
gyms and indoor restaurants will likely
be shut down
you've also heard all the calls for you
know the these thanksgiving celebrations
uh here in the us
don't have people over no more than 10
people no singing no
speaking loudly justin trudeau made a
comment just this weekend about
christmas saying that
christmas as usual will not go on in
canada i mean as we look in the next few
into the next few months
are politicians losing the confidence of
people who say
we we gave you the benefit of the doubt
in the beginning
but we don't give you that benefit
anymore because we feel like the the the
what you have imposed upon us is not
helpful
it's actually hurtful in many ways well
i think in some sense i mean that in a
way that's not true
i mean the places where shutdowns occur
and lockdowns occur and simple things
like
wearing masks have actually worked i
mean it's unbelievable that the
president of the united states
has made it clear that not wearing mass
is fine and that's killed people
so obviously the leadership has been a
major problem
um i mean the the believe the science
so i think what we've seen is this move
against believing the science
and in the in in the united states where
is it that the
the virus is spreading like crazy ants
are in republican states that listen to
trump
north dakota south dakota and another
place in the midwest
so the reality i mean the rub hits the
road but isn't it spreading
let me just challenge you on that isn't
it spreading also in new york right now
and in california where they've
instituted very strict lockdowns
well obviously the the thing has been
spreading but the reason to try and do
something like wear masks
limit spacing don't have dart at
restaurants and so i mean the answer is
what are you going to do i mean okay
you're going to say that
what are you going to do just do nothing
and let this thing explode so the answer
is no
um i mean the concern is that the
economies have to shut down if you lock
down but there's
there's various things you can do but i
don't take the premise
that there's nothing that you can do
it's basically people aren't listening
i live in florida and florida is a
disaster
as there are other places and why is
that restaurants are open bars are open
nightclubs are open
and people are traveling out there a
million people traveled yesterday
across the united states so this this
virus is exploding
because basically the president of the
united states has been completely inane
about it it's killed people
so one more question for you and we'll
bring demetrian but when you say i don't
think anyone's advocating doing nothing
but when
we talk about the cost of what's
happening what about those who say well
there's a cost in terms of suicide rates
are rising there's a cost in terms of
domestic violence that's rising there's
a cost
in terms of those issues yeah there's
absolutely no evidence to sustain that
to actually argue the suicide rates are
rising i mean you know
essentially the numbers might be in the
tens and the 20s
i mean we have 250 000 people in the
united states that i'm not an expert i'm
an economist
but that's probably one of the most
asinine arguments i've probably ever
heard
um eight people die from from suicide
compared to 2 000 people a day dying
from this terrible virus
i mean i just think those arguments are
astonishing yeah we're going to come
back to the
discussions about the economy in a
minute but i want to bring professor uh
dimitri into this and
dimitri let me ask you this in terms of
the vaccine because we keep hearing over
and over that once there is a vaccine
right that things would in theory would
go back to normal at least that's what's
been
said for almost a year now that we're
close and it seems like we are pretty
close to having a number of these
different companies
astrazeneca says that they have a
vaccine 70
efficacy modernist says they have one
that has 94
efficacy pfizer now says that theirs has
efficacy and i believe that the the
sputnik vaccine
in russia has is the claim is about 90
efficacy but and yet as we see all of
that we also see that the public says
about only about 50
of the public says they'd even be
willing to take the vaccine why do you
think there's such a disconnect
uh it always happens like this with
vaccines
even before kavit came to us we had many
dangerous diseases and we had
antioxidant movements
in my personal opinion entire machine
vaccine movement
is is rooted into psychology not into
biotechnology or medicine
therefore i would not comment on it but
what i
know is that today
is the worst day for antioxidant
movement
because at some point it will become
very clear that people who got
vaccinated
they are much healthier than people who
declined vaccination
so i fully agree with you that it's a
huge problem
for the entire humanity those 50 and 5x
50 of interaction people but
well maybe i sound harsh but maestro
koveed will correct it
so let me ask you this the efficacy
rates are
unusually high so far obviously have to
be verified but
the the claims that are being made are
unusually high we're talking about
you know efficacy rates in the 90th
percentile
for three different vaccines now if we
look at the flu the flu has had a
vaccine
and the results of those vaccines being
tracked only since 2003 here in the u.s
but from what i have seen the worst year
it was only 10
effective the best year it was only 60
effective now we know that obviously the
flu is constantly changing and there are
different
strains of flu and and that plays into
it however
when you see companies saying we've
never seen this this virus before
in history and now we're moving in a
totally different way
to try to get control of the vaccine
right doesn't that alarm people to say
a brand new vaccine comes along and all
of a sudden
you you figure it out this fast with 90
efficacy isn't there a reason to
distrust that
uh no for a very simple reason because
global science made such an amazing
effort and success in studying
coronavirus
that now only half a year well one year
after it all started
we know a lot uh it was proven by
genomic studies and i proudly have to
cite
uh professor basically and professor
gelfant that's called
scholtex kolkovo who published very nice
paper on that
this studies prove that surprisingly
this virus this coronavirus
is much less
variable and mutating than
even flu and some other dangerous
viruses
in flu virus we have many subtypes each
year new subtype arrives
so far in coronavirus despite
we sequenced tens of thousands sequences
from all around the world
we observe very little variation
very little mutation very very low
mutation rate
in principally important area against
which we will vaccinate
so uh genomics shows that we are
lucky and if it is shown by genomics
okay
let's trust it let's not believe that
something is wrong with clinical trial
let's believe that finally humanity is
likely to meet
virus that is not that changing
all right so uh david let me bring you
back in because you mentioned about the
the idea that this you know suicide rate
was it was
you know not effective enough or large
enough to really
constitute uh concern but we do have an
issue of global poverty do we not i mean
the who
for their part recently said that that
lockdowns around the world
quite possibly doubled the global
poverty rate
and if that is the case how do we
justify continuing
to lock down if you're talking about
doubling the global poverty rate isn't
that a death sentence for millions of
people
i don't know i'm an economist so i'm not
an expert on
poverty vaccines or things around the
world i didn't come on
as an expert on vaccines so i had no
idea
well the question wasn't about vaccine
it was about lockdown the continuation
of economic lockdowns doubling the
global poverty rate
i i have no evidence that that's true
okay well the who says it's true so then
the question would be
what what is what do you believe is this
there's no evidence
say again one way or the other so people
can make up stuff if they want there's
no i mean i deal in the world of
evidence
i'm an economist there's no evidence for
that so people can make that up but i'm
not going to comment on it no idea
okay so again
this is what the w.h.o has said so let's
assume that
they're not lying i'm assuming they're
not
feel free i don't know about it i i
didn't come on talk about that
about it so right so as an economist
how do we continue to lock down portions
of society
not allowing people to work not allowing
people to to go to work
no idea no idea
what do you think the solution is to
what
we're talking about are you okay yeah i
mean i don't know anything about this
this is not
something i have any expertise on so i
just it's better to speak to people with
expertise on viruses and not really not
a good idea for someone who doesn't know
about it to comment on it
so as an economist though you don't feel
comfortable commenting on the economy
i'm done thank you i'm done
[Laughter]
wow that was incredible well there you
go i guess apparently
uh david blanchflower doesn't believe as
an economist he can comment on the
economy so dmitry let's talk about
what's happening now i don't know what
upset him or bothered him so much there
but the reality is
when we talk about what's happening with
the economy when we talk about what's
happening
with the the the global poverty rate
right now and obviously you're focused
on vaccines
but we have been told over and over and
over again if we can just get to a
vaccine if we can just get to a vaccine
things will be better right and we can
reopen
remember we were originally told we
could reopen if we could just you know
keep people out of hospitals and off
ventilators that didn't happen
so the question for you becomes do you
believe
that the vaccines that are being created
right now
that are about to receive fda emergency
approval which at least one of them will
likely more than that if and when that
happens
do things go back to normal because
there are a lot of people who
as we said are suspicious of vaccines to
begin with but they're also suspicious
that
things are not going to necessarily
become better based upon
the usage of that vaccine what say you
okay hold on things will never go back
to normal
ever it is accepted already by two
groups of people
first healthcare system cannot go back
to
old normal because now it knows it must
have
extra capacity extra beds for new
viruses that will come
and big employees who send
tens of thousands of people to remote
work
are not going to bring them back all so
two things will never go back to normal
health care and big corporations
the rest of society small businesses who
suffer
from these terrible lockdowns doctors
who suffer from
everyday threat to their health these
important groups of people will get
better
because doctors will get vaccinated and
small towns
will get guests who are vaccinated so as
you see i agree that vaccination
will not solve all the problems but it
will solve
many problems
do you believe that these vaccines that
are being created
right now will require one dose or are
we going to suddenly be told it's got to
be two
or three or four doses or does it become
an ongoing
annual vaccine similar to what we see
with the flu
okay come on first of all if you read
newspapers and if you see clinical
trials
you will see that most of current toxins
require two doses so it's done already
if the clinical trial is the final legal
document on a vaccine
if a if in clinical trial you need two
doses it's over
it's not gonna be one it's not gonna be
five uh if you ask me
uh do i think
revaccination will be needed in a year
i personally do not think so
i do believe that t-cell immunity that
will come from this beautiful
mrna and adenovirus vaccine will go for
at least several years
if you ask me do i have scientific
evidence that vaccination will not be
needed one year i don't
who knows okay
right so so in the event that you're
saying you think it'll be
you know more than one time but not an
ongoing an ongoing thing
um where does that leave us in terms of
who do you think is the front runner
right now i mean moderna uses this
and i just want to break down a couple
of these things modern is using this
mrna
styled vaccine that's kind of a first of
its kind in the way that it's been
developed most of that technology came
from nih and iad
and u.s taxpayers that's what they're
using pfizer has a different kind of
vaccine johnson and johnson my
understanding has a different kind of
vaccine
and then the sputnik vaccine is
different can you just give me a quick
rundown of
what makes these uh vaccines different
from
each other and is does one become more
for lack of a better term legitimate in
your mind compared to the others based
on the technology
okay so first of all let me tell you
that i'm a
russian scientist working in
pharmaceutical innovation
so i'm proud of all three achievements
from different angles
moderna is amazing innovator
what they created is the pinnacle of
biomedical
and clinical science of the last 10
years it will be the pride of biomedical
science for the next 20 years
sputnik russian vaccine is a miracle of
russian scientists that is not as
powerful as us one
and still they produce something that
works brilliantly
i i i'm already vaccinated with sputnik
i already have my
antibodies coming from vaccination so i
know it works
so i'm proud for sputnik and
pfizer is the role model for the
industry
it's a big company that partnered with
german innovators that created beautiful
infrastructure
so i love all of them if you
want to ask me what would be my
recommendation to choose out of the
three my recommendation is
choose what is available in your
backyard
in russia we have sputnik we will choose
sputnik and yes
uh you have pfizer you will have fizer
in germany they will have
uh i mean in germany they will have
pfizer and violent attack they will have
fizer
and then yes you have modernity will
have moderna if you
go into tiny details uh
moderna is a little bit more convenient
and stable
than pfizer um sputnik is also a little
bit more convenient
so tiny details don't play they all are
brilliant
the right now it just from the data and
i just don't get mad and jump off the
ship here
like our last guest but look the the
uh the survival rate from covet based on
the numbers is about 99.6
is the survival rate of people who get
it now obviously those numbers change as
more people get it we get more data and
more data comes in
but one of the concerns one of the the
fears that people have over
over uh getting a covid vaccine is they
say well for
a lot of us for a lot of healthy
not older people people without you know
you know cardio
cardi uh cardiac vascular disease those
kinds of things
for for the average person who says i
may not need that vaccine
what do you say to them to say this is
an important thing for everyone to get
it or do you think everyone should get
it
or not get it
uh i personally i'm
quite strict i hope that we
all live in civilized educated society
we know that
we live together we have
responsibilities to each other
so if i see somebody who doesn't want to
get vaccinated
without dramatic health emergency
reasons
i am critical still i also respect
liberties of people if somebody has
religious belief that they should not
be vaccinated my suggestion is to keep
these people self-isolated but
it may come to social tension
if we keep self-isolated people who
choose not to be vaccinated
so look you're asking difficult question
if if i had a magic button
i would press it so that each person
would get vaccinated
since i don't have magic button well
there is nothing to discuss here
there is no magic button for sure to
make that happen but here's a question
do you believe that there should be
mandatory or even forced vaccinations if
necessary
i believe okay now i will say ugly thing
so
so let me be careful i believe that
government
okay i believe that government does not
have
any uh tangible tool
or vehicle to make vaccination mandatory
even in russia even so you believe that
russian uh uh government is kind of
despotic but even in russia they don't
have tools in america
it's even more than that so but i
believe that government is entitled
to play some uh ugly
games with people who don't get
vaccinated the easiest game
is to uh cancel their prospered
so easy if you have religion against
vaccination no problem you don't
travel you stay at home in your home
state you enjoy scenery but you don't
travel
and you do not um endanger other people
the professor don't you don't you
believe though i mean
and you correct me if i'm wrong but my
understanding is let's say that you get
a vaccine because you want to protect
yourself let's say that i refuse to get
a vaccine because i don't
agree with it isn't the only person
who's then in danger
the one who doesn't get the vaccine not
the one who did get it how am i
endangering you if you've had it and i
haven't
uh two two answers answer number one
no single vaccine fully protects uh
patient from uh the disease patients
still
can be infected and consequences can be
dire uh although as we know
the protection is high therefore
if we are social people respecting each
other
even if i am not vaccinated and you are
i should not say that i am in risk and
not you
i should respect even the minor
probability of danger to your health
second layer
uh well let's be real of course
we will not be able to vaccinate even 50
of the people
because of the whole range of reasons
economical logistical et cetera
so uh again
i i i believe that
during the last year approximately
30 to 40 percent of population of u.s
and russia will be vaccinated
other 60 are not necessarily
anti-vaccine they can be busy people
who cannot uh reach hospital to get
vaccinated
anyway if they start traveling around
without being vaccinated
they do anti-social thing
so my suggestion is to limit them
somehow
absolutely uh professor dimitri khalish
of schooltech thank you so much
for taking our questions and and for
answering some very tough ones there we
appreciate you taking the time to do so
thank you
i want to bring in now um paul hunter
and uh
professor paul hunter uh into this
conversation and
and cover some of the same ground and
then move into some other ground as well
uh professor thanks for being on with us
uh as part of our podcast here and i
want i want to begin by just asking you
a couple of questions here especially
from the the point of view of people who
say
lockdowns are not the answer and they're
they're destroying businesses and
they're destroying the economy
listen we understand fully this is a
difficult conversation to have
and people have passionate views on many
different sides so we're just trying to
get clarity uh as to what you know many
of our experts believe are answers here
what what do you believe
is the answer moving into the end of
this year and going into 2021
for people who say enough is enough what
we have been told has not been working
well i think it i i can certainly
understand a lot of
that debate and people on both sides of
the argument
are um uh are very very
vocal in in their views i think the
issue
is is clear that if you want to suppress
the epidemic
that some form of social restriction
until we get vaccine
is is inevitable otherwise we will get
quite um rapid growth
i think the tier system in the uk that
we had
in october did have value
and it was actually slowing the spread
of the epidemic and we saw towards the
end of october that the
epidemic started to actually level off
uh the problem uh with the uk system at
the time in my view was that
we didn't act adequately place
local authorities into the appropriate
tier
so um i certainly feel that we could
have avoided
the lockdown if we'd be
more uh reactive
in in placing local authorities into
uh the appropriate tier to control the
infection coming out of lockdown i think
we'll be going back to some form of t
well we are going back to some form of
tier system we've just heard that
today from the prime minister um
i think if we can get authorities into
the appropriate tier depending on the
state of the epidemic in their areas
then i think we can control the epidemic
yes
there is going to be a balance to be
struck between the need to control the
epidemic and to
allow our children to come continue to
get their education
and to allow the economy to do as best
as it can within the current system
so you know how you balance all those
issues is
is never easy sadly
it is certainly not easy you know we
just had a long conversation about
vaccines and about the
the upcoming vaccines from a host of
different companies
but there's no question as we discussed
with our last guest
there are a lot of people who are very
skeptical and i don't even think
skeptical's the right word
of those vaccines whether or not they'll
be as effective
as the claims that are being made and
and the reality is
professor we know that there is a
significant portion of the population
that is already saying we are not going
to take
these vaccines the promise that we keep
hearing from leaders
is it once we get the vaccine things
will you know
go back to normal can we trust even
the word normal is there a new normal
are we
having to recognize that that is the
reality of where we're headed
yeah i think the first thing to say is
that i'm actually quite confident that
we will have
really effective safe vaccines coming on
stream within
a matter of weeks and um
and i have no doubt that those vaccines
will make a big difference to the
uh pandemic and to the control of the
pandemic uh across uh much of the world
but you're quite right um there will be
a proportion possibly a substantial
proportion of the population that
will decline vaccine and in
uh societies like ours we cannot
um ignore that group and we cannot say
well because you've not had the vaccine
you know um we will um uh
uh you know you you take the
consequences of that
we have to continue to provide where
possible
a safe environment for them
but don't even with vaccine the virus
isn't going to go
away and i suspect i've been saying our
grandchildren's grandchildren
will certainly experience the infection
and and this has happened before there
are other two other very similar beta
coronaviruses that have been circulating
for decades and probably centuries
that have that made the jump some uh 100
plus years ago
what happens is that we get to uh
into some sort of harmony where they
still cause infections but they
generally just cause the common cold
and what we've got to do is try and
arrange for
society couldn't continue without as
many
fatalities as we would otherwise until
we get to that sort of
balanced state
so how do we get to a balanced state
when we have
we have on one side the medical issue
right and the other side we have the
economic issue
and we were trying to have this
discussion earlier but the the who for
their part has come out and said
um that coronavirus lockdowns globally
have contributed to quite possibly a
doubling of global poverty
that alone becomes for many millions of
people quite possibly
we don't know yet but quite possibly it
becomes a death sentence for many many
millions of people
and we're talking about people in third
world countries people
around the world who have no upward
mobility whatsoever
uh in their nations to begin with so
when you double that global poverty rate
that creates an enormous
you mentioned our children's children it
creates a generational problem does it
not
yeah i would not disagree at all with
you i think the
i think one of the issues though with
the argument is that
um often people who who say that as
uh tend to assume or tend to portray the
fact that if
if we hadn't done any lockdowns then we
wouldn't have had experienced any of the
economic hardships
any epidemic that kills more than a
million people
is going to generate economic hardships
anyway the issue is how you manage that
in a way that the
epidemic doesn't actually
by itself destroy the economy but at the
same time
um you those restrictions do the least
harm to the economy and and that's a
difficult balancing act
and and yeah to be honest he's not a
not a balancing act that public health
physicians like myself
are most appropriate to make that has to
be made by politicians taking into
account the economics
the public health requirements the
social uh
and educational needs now if we'd not
done anything
at all if we'd not had the lock down in
spring
this summer would have been a dreadful
dreadful situation in the uk
i i i'm absolutely convinced that the
lockdown
in april was necessary and essential
i think what what we have to do though
now
is as we move forward have
restrictions where they're necessary but
make sure
that we're doing the right thing as
quickly as possible and that look
where we are applying local restrictions
that they are responsive
they react quickly when things are going
out of control
in a location and we relax them as soon
as possible when things are coming back
under control
and to me that's the way that we can
manage the epidemic in a way that
minimizes the economic harm
until the point that we get a vaccine
what your mission will be like answer it
go ahead i was just gonna say wait you
mentioned about confidence
after april is is um
it's very difficult to predict at the
moment but i don't think we'll be back
to normal
um but i think things will be a lot
easier
um in the northern hemisphere when once
we've
got through march and into april
so you mentioned about politicians a
minute ago and you said ultimately
they're the ones who have to make a lot
of those decisions and
certainly in the uk it sounds like you
have some confidence in
the decisions that have been made
certainly as you said back in the spring
i will tell you here in the u.s there is
a lack of confidence certainly for
politicians
in the decisions they make because many
of the policies that seem to be pushed
forward
don't seem to to be consistent right so
for instance they'll keep liquor stores
open but then they'll close churches
they'll
allow in some in some states they allow
strip clubs to open
but churches cannot right so there's
there's an inconsis i know
it's an inconsistency certainly in terms
of policy
and then we have a whole issue you know
the governor of new jersey phil murphy
the governor
of california gavin newsom uh people who
are are
in in the federal government for
instance the speaker of the house nancy
pelosi
who will on one hand tell us all the
things that we
must do as good citizens to help protect
the world around us and then are caught
not doing it themselves and i think they
the hypocrisy
when a politician does that how damaging
is that
to any attempt to actually convey
confidence in the public
yeah i mean absolutely and i i wouldn't
want you to
go away with the idea that i'm
necessarily confident in our own
politicians here on this side of the
atlantic
um we have seen some
situations in the uk that have been very
damaging to the way this epidemic is
controlled we've seen
a number of very senior politicians
political advisors advisers to the
government on this epidemic
themselves doing things that they
have been promoting not to do and
and that and there's been research that
shows that that has actually had a
damaging impact
on people's ability and trust
in the government when um one of the
senior advisers of the government
uh decided to travel to the other end of
the country
and then go for a ride in his car with
his family
whilst they were supposed to be
self-isolating that actually had a very
bad
impact on the public perception of the
government
and the public health public's
willingness to go along with the
restrictions
um yes we have to have public health
control measures those apply to
everybody and
they should apply to everybody whatever
position in
in society that you hold otherwise
the ordinary person in the street
doesn't know what to do
and probably doesn't want to do it
anyway because
um you know people that they see on
television
are uh were flouting the rules and
um and i think that has had a very
negative impact in the way we've been
able to manage the epidemic in
in the uk should
politicians be punished when they act in
that way do you believe that they're
i mean obviously they push for you know
strict rules they can impose on the rest
of us
should the rules be go the other way
though that if you are
someone making these kinds of orders and
you yourself cannot follow them should
there be some consequence
uh well i would say so yes i mean i
think anybody
um uh who um who
openly flouts the rules um needs to give
up
their um authority to uh
the rest of the uk and we have seen that
and interestingly
on the scientist side where one of our
scientists
um broke the rules and one in scotland
the
um uh um the uh senior chief medical
officer in scotland broke the rules
herself
both of those people took what i
consider to be the honorable
um decision and resigned but we've seen
since then politicians who have
uh and and political operatives
who have broken the rules um don't feel
the same need
to uh to to um uh resign
and that's not a party political
decision because politicians on both
sides of the house of commons
have actually broken the rules and um
and uh and are still uh
in in the uh house of commons
last thing i would ask you professor is
in terms of this virus itself
which has a 99.6 survival rate is that
is that a correct number first of all
let me ask you is that a correct number
so could you say that again a
99.6 survival rate yeah
it's probably about right i mean it does
vary from one place to another
but between about the more the infection
mortality rate is probably now somewhere
between
half a percent and one percent in in the
spring
it was about it was uh quite a bit
greater than that
but um death rates have fallen
um quite a bit since since then
as a result of better and improved
treatment
right so with a 99.6
survival rate a little bit of a tongue
twister there there are people who will
look at it and say but
if you have this kind of survival rate
why are we taking as many
drastic measures still we know a lot
more about the virus than we did
you know a year ago than we did nine
months ago than we did even three months
ago
why is it that we're still continuing to
say things like
no gatherings of ten or more people shut
down
here in the u.s thanksgiving
celebrations there won't be christmas
this year virginia
i mean we we really see this idea being
being pushed very hard and i got to tell
you there are
many millions of people who look at it
and say why
why are we treating it this way when so
many the vast majority of people who get
this virus
do not die from it last word yeah well i
mean
half of one percent of people dying
doesn't actually
sound a lot until you um
extrapolate that to a population so even
if you take the uk well as about 200
million people live in the united states
assume a hundred half of those get the
infection
and half of one percent die so that is
um gosh uh that is getting on from
half a million to a million deaths from
the
uh infection in the united states if it
was left to run
its natural course is that an acceptable
number of deaths especially as many of
those would be preventable
and also it's not just the deaths we
know more about what's called long covid
now we do know that many people who
have covert infection never or at the
time haven't actually properly recovered
they've got residual lung damage
they've got residual neurological
problems
many of these people are going to put a
substantial burden
on um health care systems overcoming
uh months and years so it's not just
deaths and and some of these are
problems actually
apply to younger people as well it's not
just the elderly that suffer these
and and so yeah i mean deaths
um are a big problem but also
ultimately the extra economic burden of
long covid could
run could ultimately be more of an
economic problem than
and more of a societal problem than the
fatalities
professor paul hunter we thank you for
your time and all of your insight on
that
thank you very much all right let's
bring in jeffrey tucker now with the
american economic institute i believe
and jeffrey i believe we have you with
us right now and i want to start with
you talking about and pushing back on
some of these you have a very different
point of view i know that for a fact and
that you have
uh your view essentially is that
picking up right where this professor
left off with a 99.6
survival rate he talked about long covet
but i guess we could also define
long covid as the the overall economic
and social
damage being caused by lockdown correct
it's over it's been it's overwhelming i
mean the
the the denial of children's education
we're sacrificing a whole generation of
children denying them access to to
schooling uh
the amount of cancer treatments that
that not taking place that
we've abolished thanksgiving what the
hell are we doing and
and can i just address really quickly
what what our nice professor friend said
i i don't understand how these
scientists can get on international
television
and say things that are just
outrageously misleading like that you
can't take
a case fatality ratio that's gleaned
from a heterogeneous population with
huge gradients of risk apply it to a
population of whole and split the
numbers
and claim that the x number of people
are going to die i mean
that is fake science that was said right
here
right before i came on and this
gentleman
as nice as he is knows this the risk is
not
equal for all populations the average
age death
let me just say real quick that the
professor is not with us anymore so
he can't respond to what you're saying
but help us understand so essentially
but the question that i had asked him
was about the 99.6 survival rate
he extrapolated from that overall
population size and said
that if 100 of the population were to
contract it at this rate
therefore would equal this many deaths
that's what you're responding to
yes what he said is that ha if half the
population
contracts it at at this this current uh
case fatality rate that he estimates to
be
i forget what he said what point five
percent or something like that
then x numbers will die and he did some
math in his head i mean this is not
science the
especially since so the problem with the
infection fatality rate or the case
fatality rate those are slightly
different things
although uh that's been obscured over
the last uh
year with pcr tests that's an average of
the whole population
but if you if you break that down what
you find
is that the risk is radically
heterogeneous throughout the whole
population like i can't believe i'm
having to say this
this has been known since march that the
the risk for people under
healthy people under 40 versus under
healthy uh uh
unhealthy people over 70 is uh is a
thousand times less
i mean so you can't just take an average
and apply it to the whole population as
if we're looking at a homogeneous
gradients of risk across the whole
population that's unscientific
and it denies everything we know about
covid um
i mean let me just give you a classic uh
or what to me is
a salient example in this case
everybody's all over governor christie
known for south dakota for more or less
preserving normal life right
and they're saying oh your cases are up
okay cases are not deaths
now it's true that south dakota has a
very high
rate of deaths per million deaths per
per capita
but once you actually dig down deep into
that data
what you find is that only 21
people under the age of 40 have died
with a attribution of of coven 19.
so that is a minuscule a tiny risk
relative to the overall risk so why is
why is the
the uh cases deaths per million so high
in south dakota
well look at the number of long-term
care facilities they have they're
they're they're
very high numbers of very old and sick
people in south dakota i'm sorry to say
but that's just absolutely true and if
we're going to analyze the
the the risk profile of
of sars co v 2 we cannot do so without
a serious look at the demographics and
if you're hearing some expert on tv
failed to mention this you are not being
told what's true
so so i want to talk to you about the
great barrington declaration because
this is something that you helped to
to craft and put together i think it's
one of the most
under reported and undercovered
issues of of kind of the covet pushback
if you want to call it that
uh maybe that's not the right term but
it's essentially this idea
that while so many scientists
science being the key word here right
the science about covet is settled
you've got a lot of doctors and
scientists who are
are pushing back who are debating some
of these ideas through this declaration
correct can you
describe for our audience what it is
what the declaration is where it came
from and how many have signed
on sure you know
uh to be clear i didn't i had nothing to
do with the drafting of it
um but um i just i'm the steward of the
house that hosted
the scientists basically that's that's a
kind of a good way to look at it but uh
what happened was that you know early on
in the in the lockdowns
a lot of people were quiet a lot of
scientists were quiet because they were
just
confused like why is what's happening
contradict everything i've learned about
public health in my entire life
there must be some rationale must be
some reason and
after a little bit of delay maybe we're
talking about two or three months
finally
scientists began to speak out and i
happen to notice one of them is martin
cooler from
from from harvard who's an
epidemiologist and a statistician
and one of the people involved in and
and evaluating
vaccines and their effectiveness on the
community he looked at what was
happening
with the the carnage from lockdowns and
he began to tweet about it
right he he started a twitter account
because he felt like he had a moral
responsibility to speak out he told me
in private he said you know i have this
harvard position
and whatever 200 citations
and medical literature and stuff and i
never really understood
what i was supposed to do other than
just do what i do which is my science
but now i realize i have a
an obligation in a sense to humanity to
speak out
even though i know i'm contradicting
this strange
peculiar new orthodoxy that's going on
and so i dropped him a note i said
listen if you need a weekend retreat you
know come
come see us here so he said okay i'll be
right there and he came but he came by
and
then i invited a few other anti-lock
down i don't know
lawyers and smart people and and uh we
just
talked about covert all weekend and and
and then
and then about ten days later he called
me and he said look i think we need to
do something about this he said
he's very sweet he said the journalists
apparently
are deeply ignorant about immunology
epidemiology
and its relationship to public health
let's have a a conference
uh in great barrington where we invite
new york times
british medical journal and some other
important journalists to just
basically learn you know the fundamental
uh
facts of cell biology that's a good idea
when's it going to happen he said well
given the level of crisis i think it has
to happen this weekend so
he scrambled pretty hard but but very in
short order
jay bradatoria from stanford and sinatra
grouped sinatra
oxford and martin cooler from harvard
were here and we had
an event and then after the initial
discussions they said why don't we write
an open letter to the world and invite
people to
sign it and and they suggested they
called the great barrington declaration
you know after the
the name of the town and within um 36
hours
it was released to the world and since
that time about 40 000
scientists uh around the world have
signed it and
in addition to many other academics
historians economists
uh uh philosopher you know and so on
humanitarians
from the left and the right it just
doesn't matter um
what's gone going on in the world so
crazy that people are
that were desperate it turns out for
some sort of
way to express their disapproval of
these to these policies and endorse
public health as traditionally
understood and so now i think we have
close to 700 000 signatures
on the website and i think it has been
uh made a real difference it was their
moral courage i think inspired many
other people to finally speak out
yeah and and so the tell me about the
the barrington declaration itself so the
the great barrington declaration is
designed to essentially say
that the policies that have been put in
place so far and again
these are policies that are being pushed
by politicians by
some scientists but mostly by
politicians it seems
uh don't really match up with science
yeah that's right so um so the great
bantam declaration begins
with uh you know a basic restitution of
the facts that
that that uh sarsko v2 came to us and
that we immediately locked down
and and they discussed all the carnage
you know the fact that the hospital
stopped accepting elective surgeries
which means
cancer screenings and
all the things we'd normally use medical
services for uh
just went away and in in the united
states anyway 350 hospitals in this over
the spring and summer
actually furloughed workers because
their hospitals were empty since
all the medical services were reserved
for for cobalt but anyway
the great branching declaration which is
not long basically states
states the cost of lockdowns and then
offers an alternative strategy
observing that the risk
profile of this particular virus which
is all you should really care about in
the event of a new
virus which is who is vulnerable uh
to with faces a mortal risk from this
that's what we've always cared about in
the past
and they point out that it's a thousand
times more for people over 70 with
comorbidities
than it is for for younger people we
should not close the schools and what
they urge
and they further point out that we
cannot live in a zero covered world that
the virus like
like millions of other viruses if not
billions
have uh will is here and
and we for millionaires we've adapted
to them and how do we adapt to them
through herd immunity which is
a a point of cell biology and
uh probability mathematics actually if
you think about it like
the virus has to be smart enough to find
another host if it kills the host the
virus burns out at some point when when
there's enough immunity built up in
in a population then the virus dies out
and starts and becomes endemic it
doesn't go away it becomes endemic which
is another word for um
predictable and and also
um manageable which i think is but there
is a reality here jeffrey my
my friends tell me it's happening yeah
go ahead yeah well
the other issue here is that throughout
human history
herd immunity has been developed by
populations it's how
humans survive the idea
now that the only way herd immunity can
be reached obviously it can be helped by
a vaccine
but the only way it can be reached is
through a vaccine
uh it just seems to me to be maybe the
ultimate
twisting of science and the ultimate
twisting of
our understanding of medical practice
right that until
a pharmaceutical company comes up with
the answer for us no one can do anything
and that's where
i'm getting the most pushback from
people of saying why is it we're
supposed to believe we cannot resume
any life until we we've
taken the shot and even if that is the
case life may not resume
it's the strangest aspect of what we're
living through right now and i'm i've
resisted this idea that the lockdowns
are being driven by the pharmaceutical
companies
you know because it sounds like too much
of a conspiracy theory but there is
something very weird going on i mean in
the course of normal life for however
long
human life has existed we've our immune
systems have adapted to to new pathogens
as they
come along in fact it's one of the ben
it's one of the most extraordinary
observations from sinatra gupta who's
who's at oxford who's you know like a
philosopher of infectious diseases
in some way that she observed that in
the 20th century we've had so much trait
and so much travel
and so much contact with people who are
unlike ourselves we have the least
naive immune systems in history and this
accounts
for why one but in part for why we live
such long
lives that we've we've developed so much
exposure
that uh the we our immune systems have
gotten stronger i mean
our immune systems exist for a reason
and that's the strangest thing about 20
is that we've pretended as if the immune
system you know doesn't exist at all
which is very strange because it's like
zeroing out all the knowledge we've had
for for a hundred years it's like it's
suddenly gone and we think
that the only cure for disease is for
people to sit in labs and and concoct
some
uh potion that they're gonna inject into
us and there's a lot of confusion about
what this potion consists of
i think the popular understanding of
vaccines
is that it builds a wall you know
between you and the disease kind of like
you know if you download a virus
protection program on your computer
and the virus comes in and then the
computer stops it from infecting your
hard drive
right that's how people think of
vaccines and their relationship to
viruses i
actually think this is a linguistic
confusion the only way
in the biological and natural world that
vaccines work is by
interplaying with a functioning immune
system so
it can give your immune system a kick
and we
sometimes they perform miracles look
what happened to smallpox i mean that's
a glorious
and the signature case of the the best
vaccine that we've ever had
but the problem is that vaccine is not
necessary for people who otherwise can
develop natural immunities
and that's it's a good thing to develop
natural immune it is a natural immunity
is naturally acquired immunity is always
safer and effective
than than any vaccine and i'm
for especially for for mild respiratory
illnesses which sarge kobe 2 is and i'm
saying this not as
i'm an economist not a cell biologist
but i'm relying on the
authority of others in observing that
but the other problem is that the
vaccine will be ineffective for people
without functioning immune systems
and it's an empirical question how many
of the people
who have died from
covert 19 have had non-functioning
immune systems
in which case they would not have been
improved by the existence of a vaccine
at all
i don't know the answer to that is it is
it 20
50 90 i don't know it's an empirical
question but the fact that this isn't
even being discussed is
to me something of a scandal i have one
more question for you before i let you
go
uh jeffrey and and it is an economics
question it's also a markets question
free markets question
you know we have this talk of vaccines
certainly uh
the moderna vaccine uh the
mrna technology that's been developed
there was not
a modernist development it actually was
developed by
government scientists working in the nih
moderna signed a contract
with the nih in december of last year to
start working on projects together
but you know it's already been
established that not only does
not belong to moderna but scientists
from the nia nih have actually filed for
patents
alongside moderna so that they can make
money off of this my question for you is
if u.s taxpayers in operation warp speed
spend 2 billion
on a pfizer vaccine you know they spend
two billion dollars
uh going to modernity for their vaccines
should these companies be allowed to
charge or should the vaccines themselves
be free
to the public how do we have government
government-funded scientists
developing in in government-funded
programs
the vaccine technology which is then
paid for
in advance to the development to these
companies and then we're still supposed
to pay for vaccines when the time comes
and and and and ben let's just be clear
about what a patent amounts to it means
uh a legal protection for one company to
be the sole
producer of of what would easily be
reverse engineered by other people
uh so there's nothing free market about
about a patent
and nothing free market about a
pharmaceutical patent especially it's a
basically a government privilege
towards a capitalistic uh company that
does
not want to compete in the market so i
think you ask a
really important question here and i
think uh in the coming years we're
really going to have to come to terms
with this i mean
ben really the question is did we
destroy new york did we destroy the
united states do we destroy the world
and any
semblance of what we used to call human
rights and civilization
so that a handful of companies could
make monopoly profits by enforcing
patents contrary to all market logic
you know that is a terrifying question
and it's actually almost too much for me
to even uh
to even contemplate right now but we're
going to have to come to terms with it
yeah i think we do have to come to terms
with it and i think this idea that
when we talk about you know what is
happening to our
economies because it's not just one
economy right it's economies around the
world and it's certainly
multiple economies throughout the united
states and what people are living
through and struggling with
when we hear the talk of what happens in
the next
six months the next year 2021
does the entire year also become part of
the system and if that is the case
jeffrey are we looking at a realignment
of
of global economics and certainly
companies like amazon
certainly the big tech companies and
corporations
seem to be doing fine during these times
but it's those small businesses
does covet have the potential to wipe
out
the middle class not just in america but
worldwide
it seems to be that's what we're trying
to do we've created a new feudalism and
i'll just tell you a little bit of an
anecdote you know what i'm talking about
here
uh uh primitive societies a pre-modern
society is always
assigned to some one class to bear the
burden of funeral
of herd immunity on behalf of ruling
class and i think that's what we're
doing here
i must tell you i i went out to a
restaurant last night there's something
profoundly disturbing
about watching fancy people sit at
dinner
sucking down cocktails and enjoying
fancy food while a weight staff
and cooks and and everybody is is
wearing gloves and masks as if they're
the unclean people that that service us
that is not the way we do it under
freedom and democracy and equality this
is wrong
it's disgusting and it is absolutely
heartbreaking and
what i just described is the microcosm
of what's happening all over the world
the ruling class is getting its way
using largely bogus science and state
coercion
in a way that's at the expense of our
health our families our religions our
faith
everything we've ever valued our
national traditions everything our right
to travel everything we've ever valued
and and the only people who are winning
from these lockdowns to the ruling class
every day i've woken up for the last
11 months and 10 months and hoped it
would be over
and i don't think we can give up hope i
just hope that you know
that tomorrow we'll wake up in the
morning and realize we're not going to
put up with this anymore
and we're going to go back to uh public
health
uh freedom democracy some semblance of
equality and normalcy so we can get on
with building civilization instead of
destroying it
jeffrey tucker thank you so much for
your time and for all of your insight
and i think i'll walk away from this
interview with
with the phrase we have the least naive
immune systems in history that's going
to stick with me
appreciate your time thank you
let's bring on dr scott jensen he is a
state senator uh in the state of
minnesota but he is a physician and i am
uh
excited to bring him on because there is
a this part of this discussion that i
think is so critically important and
scott i i it's good to have you on here
i got to tell you you
post these facebook videos where you're
explaining your situation what's been
happening with you i reshare them all
the time
because i think that your story is such
an important story for people to hear
you are a physician and you have had now
your medical license and you can correct
me if i'm
i'm wrong on this uh challenge now twice
going before the medical board because
of comments that you have made
about the response to coronavirus
correct
that's correct tell me about the
comments that you made
that were reported what did you say
well the first time around i was accused
of spreading misinformation because i
had compared
coven 19 to influenza in a fashion
similar to what dr
fauci and dr mike osterholm in minnesota
have done
so i was astonished about that i was
also accused of
uh providing reckless advice
and that was in late june and then that
was dismissed in late july
and then in august another investigation
was initiated and that time i was
identified as a
a danger to public health because i took
the 2009 swine flu
pandemic and tried to draw comparisons
between it and our present situation
in regards to a variety of features
seasonality
uh length of time what kinds of
mitigating measures might have been
tried in 2009 versus 2020
and for that i was a danger to public
health and then that was dismissed
in october so right now my
i'm happily not being investigated
and we're glad to hear that but i have
to ask you you know there is a
whole other part of this story right
which is you know we have
the politicians of what they're saying
and we have separately from that
um this idea that scientists and doctors
are all in one
one mindset jeffrey tucker just talked
about the thousands 40 000
scientists and doctors who have signed
his declaration there seems to be
an absolute just squashing
of any voice that says something that is
contrarian if you
if you say something to the contrary of
what social media companies have deemed
as acceptable if you say something
that's contrary about coronavirus
um you are immediately not just censored
but threats against your livelihood
against your ability to practice
medicine
i mean it just seems we hear so much
talk today about stand up against
fascism
it seems like such a fascist idea
i couldn't agree with you more i mean i
think back to march
i was attacked by bureaucrats because
they said that
i was minimizing the impact of cover 19
and i simply was trying to provide
context in our country
i think a lot of folks don't realize
that we have almost 10 000 people die
every day in the united states one out
of
100 people in the united states
dies every year we have something in
excess of 300 million people but
3 million people die every year these
are not
alarmist statements these are not
conspiratorial statements these are
facts
and so when i started being criticized
in march and then in
april i saw the if you will the bogus
advice we were getting as to how to
complete death certificates
i said well this is crazy and then in
may i was being criticized by some of my
colleagues in the senate because
they felt i was trivializing the present
situation and
i'm not trying to trivialize i'm just
trying to provide some reasonable
perspective then june july august
september i
spent defending my my license i don't
think there's any question
that there is a divide that is
astonishing i mean i lived through the
1960s
civil rights movement i lived through
the vietnam piece
this is remarkable and honestly
i think one of the notable sources of
blame
belongs on physicians
i don't think that we have held up
science at the level we should
science is just three things it's
observation it's measure
and then it's hypothesized hypo create a
hypothesis
that would explain what you saw and
measured and
then develop an experiment to either
confirm or deny your hypothesis and ask
other scientists to do the same it's at
that point that we have
science but if you actually look at what
we did in 2009
and look at what we're doing now
everything changed on a dime
four or five months ago there was no
talking about randomized control
yes i'm talking about if you look what
we did with influenza with 2009 swine
flu
and look at what we're doing now and the
mitigating policies
in 2009 we did not close schools lock
stock and barrel we did not lock down
uh we did not go crazy about the value
of masks
we did not do any of these things in
everything flipped about four or five
months ago not because we had good
science
randomized controlled studies
double-blinded studies
peer-reviewed studies we had just a lot
of
panic and fear and we had a lot of
gobbledygook a lot of mud thrown on the
wall
and we were just picking and choosing
and everybody's saying heavens to betsy
this guy is falling we've got to do
something so
we're going to make a mask mandate fine
that's not a hill i'm going to die
on but i think if we have vulnerable
people thinking that they're doing what
they need to do
by wearing a mask we're hurting them
because
we're actually lulling them into
potential care
we'll focus on protecting the vulnerable
people that's where your quarantines go
that's who gets the most support but
what we've done is flipped it around
we've said
we're going to take the population of
people that are least vulnerable
the zero to 30 year olds and we're going
to lock them down we're going to say no
school
we're going to say no phonetics no
ability to learn how to
talk and write as a six-year-old or a
seven-year-old
with a teacher having no mask on what
we've done we will pay for for
decades well and i think to that point
as we've been talking about this today
that seems to be the the place of
disconnect for most
americans and a lot of people around the
world i mean we see protest movements
happening in germany this past weekend
there was a huge protest in germany
uh of people pushing back against the
second round of lockdowns
but i think this idea that the
for a lot of people there is a huge
disconnect between what they see
as the reality of what's going on around
them the people around them the people
they know who have contracted it
remember back in
april and may very few people knew
anyone who had contracted covet now
many people know people who have
contracted it and and so what we
see around us versus what we're being
told and it feels like
that's where the the if for lack of a
better term a rebellion to this idea
seems to be growing from is that i'm
seeing something with my eyes but you're
telling me not to trust my eyes you're
telling me not to trust
what i what i'm what i do know in
exchange for what i
don't know that you were telling me um
what can people do to become smarter
about this issue to become
more informed on this without having to
just swallow whatever they're hearing
in the media well i think you just made
a very good point
you said other than just swallowing what
they see in the media
i would say this i would say that
initially
we talked about a divide or a fracture
of the trust
then we started to see people saying
what you said
what you're telling me isn't matching up
with what i'm seeing so at that point in
time we move from trust
to a fracture of trust to disbelief
when you move from disbelief to the next
step
it depends upon what's happening to you
in your individual life
if your individual life is being
hyper-controlled
damaged you now start to react with
anger
and i think that's what we're seeing
today i think and that's made the divide
bigger
because we have on one side people say
do whatever the government tells us to
do
and you have another group saying listen
we've moved from fractured trust
to disbelief we're angry now and i think
that that's what we're seeing and
honestly
i participated in the world doctors
alliance i participated in
by zoom in trafalgar square
demonstrations
and in copenhagen and i've been with the
frontline doctors
in this country the barrington
declaration was a
very reasonably well-stated alternative
to
how we're doing things and that was just
unbelievably criticized so we're now
seeing attacks come left and right
and people are just exhausted
and yet they're looking at some of the
data and they're saying well hold it
if on the testing we're told over and
over again
that they're running too many cycles and
then it may well be that
more than 50 percent in some samplings
are false positives and the
case fatality rate is actually excuse me
the infectious fatality rate
is dropping they're saying i just can't
buy what you're selling
and honestly i don't even know if i want
to listen anymore and that's a dangerous
place too
absolutely for taking the time to meet
with us with us
to discuss all of us not having to go
right now right now
thank you for having me so let's bring
him astrazeneca are the latest company
to join the front runners in the kobit
19 vaccine race
announcing an efficacy of 70 percent
after concluding
their phase 3 trials now though these
preliminary results may sound
humble compared to other vaccines the
company's ceo is optimistic
saying the job will be highly effective
and will have an immediate impact
with the uk having already pre-ordered a
hundred million jabs
boris johnson is more than happy with
the results
incredibly exciting news the oxford
vaccine has proved so effective in
trials
there are still further safety checks
ahead but these are fantastic
results well done to our brilliant
scientists at the university of oxford
and astrazeneca
and all who volunteered in the trials so
why the relatively low efficacy well
developers say that
70 figure is an average of two dosage
regimens
two high doses gave a result of 62
with a high dose following a low one
raising efficacy to 90 percent
now this 70 percent average figure is
therefore
lower than trial results announced
earlier by modena
at 95 percent also pfizer at 95
though that company raised their
efficacy from an initial
90 result with the russian sputnik v
vaccine standing at 92.
now these figures are crucial given the
highly competitive nature of the market
and it's been a bumpy road for
astrazeneca now today as these results
were published the company's shares
actually
fell on the back of the lower than
expected average efficacy
even as european stocks rose on the good
news
of another vaccine entering the market
now the vaccine trials had to be halted
in september because of a serious
suspected adverse reaction in the
participant
and in october one of the volunteers in
brazil died
causing uncertainty about its future
why the advanced trial of a promising
vaccine was suddenly paused
astrazeneca has paused its trials after
an unexplained illness in a participant
in the uk
as one company makes huge strides in the
vaccine race another drug
giant hits the pause button on its late
stage trials
volunteer in one of the most advanced
coronavirus vaccine trials
in the world has died and despite the
news astrazeneca's testing
continues well those adverse effects
were investigated
and though the company and the brazilian
health authority refused to comment in
detail on the case
the trial was deemed safe to continue
though in the united states the delay
lasted several weeks
and today's results don't include data
from american trials
despite the lower efficacy the upside to
this vaccine is
cost effectiveness while the estimated
price of the fisa vaccine is around 19.
the
modena jab between 25 to 37 those prices
go up to over 40 dollars and as high as
74 respectively
for the total treatment at the cost of
the sputnik v vaccine is estimated at
twenty six dollars per treatment though
final costs are yet to be announced the
astral zeneca jab will not only be
easier to manufacture and store but the
cost for both
uh doses could be as low as eight
dollars
well the race is now on to register
these vaccines astrazeneca stated it
would seek emergency use listing from
the world health organization
with russia saying they've already begun
the sputnik v registration process
despite the good news it's too early to
say we've seen the back of the pandemic
even with these promising trial results
this
is not the time for complacency
while we continue to receive encouraging
news about covet 19 vaccines
and remain cautiously optimistic about
the potential
for new tools to start to arrive in the
coming
months right now we're extremely
concerned
by the surging cases we're seeing in
some countries
particularly in europe and the americas
health workers and health systems are
being pushed
to the breaking point even with several
vaccines hitting the market in coming
months
with the world in the grip of the second
covert 19 wave there's still a
very long and difficult road ahead until
we see a return to at least
some semblance of normality
so again a lot of information they're
specific to these vaccines the different
vaccines that
are about to hit the market so joining
us now to go more in depth on that
particular issue
is robert f kennedy jr he is with
children's health defense and
robert great to have you here i really
wanted you to be on this
program today because of this issue
specific to these vaccines and i want to
start with this question
astrazeneca says 72 percent efficacy
their stock dropped because of that
but the other three moderna 94 efficacy
pfizer 95 efficacy and and sputnik v
92 efficacy how can we believe these
kinds of efficacy rates
when when we know that the best a flu
vaccine is ever done
is 60 efficacy according to the fda
why would we believe that these vaccines
all suddenly
got it exactly right the first time
around and in record time
well i you know my reaction um
then is actually um
that well you know let's let's talk
about how they get those numbers the way
that they get those numbers
is fizer gave 22 000 people the vaccine
and 22
000 people the placebo and then it
waited
until 100 people got sick from coven
and it was double-blinded supposedly
which we have to assume is true for the
moment
and that means that neither researchers
nor the
uh the subjects the volunteers or
recruits
knew whether they were getting the
placebo or the vaccine
and they wait for a hundred of those
people to get sick
and they actually they waited till 95
people got sick
and then they unplanned the study and
they look at how many of those people
were from the vaccine group and how many
of them were from the placebo group
and as it turned out 95 of the people in
the
pfizer study were from the vaccine group
and so that's good news you know there's
a couple of good things about
the mrna vaccine if they can actually
get it to work
which i'm skeptical about but i'm very
open to
if they can get it to work it would be
much better it would be preferable to
traditional vaccines
because it doesn't have the kind of
ingredients it doesn't need an adjuvant
it's not aluminum it doesn't have
mercury preservatives doesn't have
formaldehyde and
you know most some of them the modern
one doesn't have human fetal tissue
and so it's potentially a safer
vaccine than the typical ones that we
and
vaccines that we're getting today um
the question we have is
how long does the immunity last
is there immune enhancement in other
words are there a certain percentage of
people who are going to get the magazine
and actually get
sick or from covid which is what they've
seen in the past
and then the question is the side
effects and
of the modern vaccine 100
of the people had some adverse effects
many of them mild
after the second dose in the phase one
trial
twenty percent of a high dose twenty one
percent of the idols group
had serious effects meaning
hospitalizations or medical intervention
required six percent of the low dose
group
had serious side effects and that means
that it's a dose-related response which
is
in dish of toxicity the question is now
we have not
seen pfizer's safety data so
if fizer safety data looks anything like
that
and we have to question ourselves is it
better to get covered
for most pop for most age groups
or to get the vaccine if you're under 55
your chance of suffering an injury from
the vaccine is about
one-tenth the according to cdc's own
data
about one-tenth of the injury serious
injury and death rate
of the seasonal flu
so for that age group
any injury would be unacceptable from
the vaccine
because if you're not going to get hurt
by covet
why would you take a vaccine that has
maybe a 10
chance of hurting you and particularly
we don't know what happens to people
who have comorbidities and so we really
need to parse through the
the safety in it and look at the safety
impacts for particularly seniors for
elderly for the fragile elderly and for
people with comorbidities
right now one of the problems with the
way that they did that test ban
is that nobody in the test died
so we don't know whether the vaccine
prevents
deaths or whether it prevents injuries
you know serious injuries because those
weren't tested for
as you pointed out with the flu vaccine
what the cochrane collaboration and what
bmj
have said about the flu vaccine is that
there is no proof
that the flu vaccine prevents any
hospitalizations or any deaths
it prevents you have to give between 70
and 100 flu vaccines to prevent one case
of mild
illness and in some cases a mild illness
it may make moderate symptoms more mild
do we really want an 18 billion dollar
vaccine program
that just makes moderate symptoms more
mild
in some affected people if it does
nothing to prevent
injuries serious injuries and deaths and
nobody can say that about this vaccine
we just don't know because the test
as peter doshi from the british medical
journal said
and as dr hazeltine from harvard said
these
trials were designed to succeed they
weren't designed to tell us
whether this vaccine is going to prevent
any injuries or any deaths
or whether it blocks transmissibilities
and this is a big issue
according to tony fauci
these vaccines do not block
transmissibility
that means you get them and we know that
in the monkey trials the astrazeneca
vaccine
the monkeys were still after they got
the vaccine their symptoms became
milder but they were still transmitting
covet
so what happens when you give the
population
these vaccines and it doesn't prevent
those same people
from transmitting the disease you simply
turn them all
into asymptomatic carriers and that
doesn't end the lockdown
it doesn't end the mass and isn't
even that idea i mean what you just said
about asymptomatic carriers if that is
the case
if if and i haven't you know studied it
well enough to know
if that would be the case but if that
were the case that it turned
everyone who got the vaccine into an
asymptomatic carrier doesn't that
do precisely what we're trying to
prevent
by creating lockdowns in the first place
by making people wear masks
exactly it turns us all into kind of
typhoid mary's
you know there was a very very important
study that was published this morning in
nature
and it was published by the wuhan
um institute of virology was an
extensive study that was conducted with
the cooperation of the chinese
government
where they tested 10 million people they
were trying to figure out whether there
is
a symptomatic transmission in covet and
what their conclusion was
in this study is that there is no
asymptomatic transmission
they tested 10 million people with not
just what not pcr
tests which you know as you know often
exaggerate the um
you know give us a lot of false
positives but they tested um
um with accurate testing and that of the
10 million people they found i think
there was only about 300 of them
that were asymptomatic
and they who were carriers who tested
positive
and they didn't show symptoms and they
went out
and they did extensive contract contact
racing which they can do in china
because everybody has followed around
and they were able to trace
every single person that those 300
people ever came into contact with
and there was no case of asymptomatic
transmission
so the scientists and the most important
study ever done on this are now
saying that asymptomatic transmission
does not occur with covid
that's the best science we have on that
right now
and as you said that was what you would
be doing that was
yeah it was published this morning and
what they were
you know what were uh so i have not read
it all the way through so excuse me if i
got something wrong but that's my kind
of understanding from reading the
abstract
and and glancing through the paper
but what they what could happen is that
the vaccine could actually make things
much worse these vaccines if they do not
prevent transmissibility
and the weird thing about this and is
that
nobody from the press is asking the one
question that counts
do these vaccines prevent transmission
and if they don't does that do they turn
us
all into asymptomatic carriers
and how does that work and none of those
questions are being asked we're being
you know the press is focused on
these big headlines that it's 95
effective
and nobody's saying against what
against mild symptoms and they're not
saying
does it actually stop you from spreading
the disease
and if it doesn't do that then what's
the point
what is that well that's that becomes
the big question is what is the point i
want to ask you though
um about the fact that you've been so
heavily censored
uh on social media and your ability to
speak and
primarily to question because that's
what i see
that comes from from your social feeds
more than anything else
are serious questions you just said the
media won't ask the right questions you
have attempted to ask questions
but your voice has been silenced on
these issues it's not just about saying
well no one cares what you have to say
it's it almost seems as if too many
people maybe care about what you have to
say
therefore they're not allowed to hear
you can you just touch on that briefly
for us i mean
what has it been like for you for the
last few weeks and months since
essentially your social media has been
been shadow banned
well it's frustrating i mean we've been
censored for 15 years in the mainstream
media
which is you know is pharma-controlled
but we were able to talk pretty freely
on social media on facebook on instagram
and twitter until 1919 um
the in when the who
made the announcement who which of
course is controlled by bill gates
made the announcement that uh vaccine
hesitancy
was one of the greatest threats the
global threats to public health
immediately after that adam schiff wrote
a letter to all of the
who's the head of the intelligence
committee by the way
to the chair of the comm intelligence
committee to all the
um to the social media ceos
and then met with them and asked them to
begin
censoring us and you know this has not
happened before in american history
um there has been you know some kind of
voluntary censorship for example
during the mccarthy era and there's been
small
outbreaks of censorship but right now we
have
we have essentially the government using
these social media platforms as
surrogates
the censor speech that challenges
government policies and so far the
courts have said that the
first amendment does not apply to those
cases because these are private carriers
we've now brought a lawsuit
against facebook that says you're not a
private
carrier in this case because the
government told you to do this and you
are coordinating the
censorship which they're open about with
who
and with cdc so you have cdc telling
them
what to censor and what not to censor
and then you know the censorship the the
the the fact-checking outfits that
they're using to censor us are also some
of those are financed by government
agencies
but we've said in this case the first
amendment doesn't apply
in our case because they're actually
censoring us
as a surrogate of government action and
we'll see what happens that lawsuit i
think it should win
the thing that people need to understand
about the first amendment and i think
democrats have somehow forgotten this
which is shocking to me
being a democrat at the first amendment
that
the founders put the first amendment in
the constitution
not to protect people who were trying to
make
you know to speak popular words
or to protect speech that was convenient
and that was agreeable and that was nice
they put it in the constitution to
protect
inconvenient speech unpopular speech
people you know all of our rights are
not to protect things that everybody
agrees with
and particularly things that the
government agrees with our rights are
there
to protect our capacity
to express dissent against government
policies against pharmaceutical products
against
you know on corporate power
and right now and that is really the
foundations on
american democracy that the founder said
you know when we were in england
if he if the king didn't like what you
said
he could he could jail you he could shut
you up
he could close down your newspaper he
could silence speech
he could stop people from assembling he
could stop you from petitioning the
government
and all those rights are being removed
from the american people
and for some strange reason there's no
broad
scale protest about this censorship and
that
is um you know those two things are
worrying one that the censorship is
occurring
and two that you know the large amount
of them
of the american people and the
democratic party are not objecting to it
but the rather they're endorsing it
yeah in many ways robert f kennedy jr
thank you so much
for your time today and and speaking out
on the subject thank you
thank you ben before we go uh we
actually we're supposed to be rapping
but we're gonna bring in one more guest
because we have an important test to get
to dr
reiner fumik is with us now and uh he
is in germany and my understanding is uh
is actually uh filing a lawsuit
uh you correct me if i'm wrong filing a
lawsuit over many of the lockdowns that
have occurred around the world and you
say it's because of these
i'm going to read it here current
geopolitical changes in the world
are regarded as crimes against humanity
can you speak to that
yeah well we filed that lawsuit today
here in germany it's part of
a larger strategy of lawsuits we are
uh in very close cooperation with
bobby kennedy's chd and his team of
attorneys
but this is the first step we believe
which
i think will attack
the cornerstone of the current crisis
which are the pcr tests because we
believe
after having listened to dozens of
experts since
uh july 10th here in berlin
uh in our corona investigative committee
we believe that this is a staged
pandemic this is nothing this is nothing
to do with health
uh but everything to do with what bobby
kennedy just talked about
um the uh they're they're very concrete
dangers for democracy in particular
for free speech so we believe that in
order to make this house of
cards collapse we have to attack the pcr
test because in the meantime we have
learned from the who that the
actual danger of this so-called pandemic
is no
worse than that of a common flu at 0.14
uh percent infection fatality rate and
we also know that there are no
um asymptomatic infections
um so what is left is the pcr test
we know that uh from listening to our
witnesses we know that this particular
now so-called drusden pcr test which
supposedly tells you something about
infections does not tell you anything
about infections
but rather it is being used as a tool
to keep people in panic mode and not ask
any questions about
what they are supposed to do like mask
wearing requirements uh
social distancing the lockdowns
okay so let me get a little bit of
clarification here on some things
so you said that the lawsuit was filed
this morning uh who have you filed
against
where this is a defamation lawsuit we
are our plaintiff is dr wolfgang vodak
i don't know if you've heard about him
he's the person who more or less
single-handedly uh stepped in 12 years
ago when something very similar to
what's happening now
was about to happen namely the swine flu
he's the one who was then in a a
position of political power he was a
member of the german parliament
and he was also a member of the council
of europe
and he managed back then to stop things
from getting any worse
even though it had gotten pretty bad at
the time that he stepped in
because they were already uh
vaccinating people with a hastily
invented vaccine which eventually did
a lot of damage to i think 700 children
here in europe they're now permanently
disabled
suffering from narcolepsy but he's the
one who stopped this
and he um he he did great work
showing uh to the to the general
population in
throughout the world that even then this
so-called
swine flu wasn't any worse was just a
mild flu
eventually and that's what we believe
this is
so so he's the person you're suing
though
no no he's the plaintiff and we're
assuming a group of people
yeah we're suing a group of people uh
so-called
fact checkers which uh they're not of
course they're manipulating the truth
um they're being hired by the
corporations that bobby kennedy's
spoke about uh by youtube
facebook and facebook and twitter
exactly and we're suing them because and
this is clad
in a defamation lawsuit i'm doing this
for
reasons of burden of proof
this group of people is accusing dr
vodak of lying
when he says that the pcr tests uh
are unreliable and cannot tell you
anything about infections
so we're doing two things we're killing
two birds and with one stone
on the one hand we're protecting dr
vodak
who is back in the picture now back and
and who's visible now for the general
public because
as i said he's the one who uh who did
a great job uh 12 years ago uh
unmasking so to speak the uh swine flu
and at the same time we're attacking uh
the
the people who are behind this behind
this staged pandemic by
uh attacking the pcr tests
so when you say uh that you're attacking
the pcr tests what you're saying
is you're doing that through a
defamation lawsuit
if i'm understanding this correctly
saying dr voda is being attacked on
social media or censored
or or defamed on social media
because of statements he's making about
the pcr test
therefore we are suing for defamation in
order to force
those fact checkers to present their
evidence as to why these statements that
he has made about pcr tests are untrue
do i have that correct
precisely and you even got the burden of
proof correct because it's up to them to
prove that he's lying but the
complaint that we've written is uh very
well stocked with
lots of evidence already uh testimony
and expert testimony and uh
publications by experts in scientific
journals including professor camera who
is a biologist and immunologist uh
at the university of wurzburg here in
germany including
dr mike yeah you may have heard of him
he's a former vice president of pfizer
and uh i think he was for 16 years he
was their chief science officer
but there's others as well so this is
not uh
something to be taken lightly and i
think the other side will know this once
they read this
i think what's interesting because
obviously you know it just to be clear
here as a disclaimer
you know i have no evidence that pcr
tests don't work i have no evidence that
they're flawed
having said that this strategy
is very interesting to me because of the
fact that the fact checkers
let's be clear about this whether it's
in germany whether it's in
the uk or here in the united states
right or australia
the fact checkers themselves never seem
to present
evidence as to any of the reasons why
information is removed or censored taken
down
you know thrown down the memory hole
there that burden has never been placed
on them legally to say
we have proof that the person here is
lying they simply label you
as someone who is untruthful or
spreading misinformation
so the fact that they would be required
to then come forward and present
evidence that proves one thing or
another do you believe that you are
setting a precedent
uh by doing this that can be followed
almost a blueprint that could be
followed in other countries as well
excellent you got it you hit it right on
the spot that's precisely what we're
doing that's why we this is going to be
a precedent
this is this is one of many many many
uh complaints we're going to uh file
here in
in germany and throughout europe through
the uh
uh other law firms in
all the german-speaking countries
australia switzerland
i'm sorry austria switzerland but also
the other countries
lawyers who we cooperate with but this
same
complaint is going to be used or a large
part of it is also going to be used by
our american
and canadian colleagues because in the
meantime everybody agrees
all the lawyers who have kind of dug
into this
all the all of them agree that the pcr
test
is the cornerstone of this entire hoax
uh and again um
is there any evidence that you can
provide today that shows the pcr tests
don't work yeah there's no
scientists in this entire world who will
claim that a pcr test can detect
infections
pcr tests are not designed
for diagnostic purposes they're not
admitted for diagnostic purposes
i've seen all the videos by the inventor
of the pc a pc artist is a great tool
it makes things visible to the human
eyes which
are otherwise not visible by amplifying
it by making
those molecules that you take with these
swabs larger
so that eventually you can see what this
is all about
but they are not in any way
capable of telling you anything about
infections in particular not
when these pcr tests are set at
more than 25 cycles everybody agrees
because cycles of amplification that is
everybody agrees including the new york
times which is part of the mainstream
media
which again as bobby kennedy just
alluded to
is apart from investing their money in
the pharmaceutical and tech industry
they've also
the other side i'm calling them they've
also invested
invested much of their money in the
mainstream media but even the new york
times
in a in an article that was published in
august of this year
agrees that um anything beyond 35 cycles
is completely and utterly unscientific
and completely useless now the tests
were talking about
the infamous dresden test which is what
the so-called professor dressed in here
from charity university in berlin
invented
in order to uh show the world
that uh by using these tests you can you
can see infections you can detect
infections
this test was used worldwide because it
was pushed
by the w.h.o as a sort of gold standard
to find out about how many infections
there are with covet
19. fascinating stuff
uh dr reiner fuelmik thank you so much
for taking the time today and personally
i wish you great luck in your lawsuit
against those tech companies and their
censorship i think it's needed badly
not just in germany but worldwide thank
you
thank you very much and thank you guys
for tuning in to the podcast today i
hope that we have helped to shed some
light on what's going on
again with the coronavirus with the
issue of vaccines and masks
and of shutdowns whether they be
personal shutdowns
or social shutdowns or economic
shutdowns because
all of it as i said is affecting all of
us worldwide we will continue to hold
those who are in power accountable
and we will continue to dig in on this
issue you can find the very latest of
course always
at rt.com i'm ben swann thanks for
watching and we'll see you again soon
[Music]
so
you